johnny depp might just be in beetlejuice
too
and
i'm going to discuss the trial and the
very personal reasons why i haven't
discussed it so far
welcome to sidetrack your scifi tv and
movie channel
[Music]
hello and welcome everybody to this very
quick um video live video because i
really do want your comments on this um
regarding johnny depp and well rumors
that he's going to be in betelgeuse too
so where these rumors come from
to be honest they're kind of coming from
everywhere but mostly from imdb
but they are rumors at this point we we
don't know if this is 100 true but there
are good reasons why we maybe should
believe this
so the beetlejuice ii um
rumors have been around for ages
basically for about three decades we've
been waiting for a sequel of this film
um but they've been getting stronger and
stronger over the last 12 months or so
the the rumor is basically that oh i
said basically again i need to take a
drink every time i say basically
the rumor is that
michael keaton is signed on winona ryder
is coming back and some of the other
characters
and now also johnny depp but why would
we believe this
well
it's a movie made by plan b which did
charlie the chocolate factory we'll talk
about crap show in a minute um and this
film is actually going to be produced by
tim burton and as we know
michael um johnny depp appears in every
single tim burton movie ever made
so yes i'm gonna have a new drinking
game unfortunately there isn't any
actual alcohol in it but um yeah every
time i say basically
i'll take a slip
it's just annoying when you do things
like this that you start getting little
little twerks into your speech and then
they become annoying but anyway um
so yeah plan b which is a company
co-owned by prague bad
brad pitt and a couple of other people
and like i said that they made charlie
chocolate factory
now charlotte chocolate factory is one
of those rare films
that makes me want to take my own
manhood put it in a vice and squeeze
until
stuff pops i i would rather do that than
what's charlie the chocolate factory
again the original gene wilder movie was
perfection they did not need to make a
sequel but when they did they made it
creepy and weird like tim burton tends
to do
now we do have problems with tim burton
as well as as a movie maker but we won't
go into that right now
but what do i feel about johnny depp
potentially being in this movie or the
rumors of dragged up being in this movie
well hey shelly how are you
one of our amazing business shelly runs
our facebook group she's absolutely
amazing she's got it we're pushing a
thousand so if you can go search
sidetrack on facebook and go find us
shelley will welcome you she's amazing
um
so
tim burton for one let's talk about tim
burton
um he makes awful movies he makes really
good story ideas and makes them weird
and creepy sometimes and then he makes
amazing movies sometimes
he has a very good friend's friendship
with helena bonham carter who's married
to us should do and obviously johnny
depp and johnny depp has appeared in
many movies so why do i feel he might
want johnny depp to appear in his movie
even though johnny depp has been a
little bit of a pariah in um hollywood
recently well he was a prior
until this second trial started and then
his star has re-risen his public opinion
is massively swung in his favor um but
we'll talk about the trial in a minute
so i actually believe johnny depp could
appear in betelgeuse 2 as almost like a
favor from tim burton and that's maybe a
little unfair
but
i can imagine that tim burton would be
really passionate about wanting to get
johnny depp into this movie sort of like
a big comeback you know i could see
johnny depp doing like um a bit of a bad
guy role in this and can you imagine him
and michael keaton going toe to toe with
each other acting
who can do the most crazy it would
actually be pretty cool so i could i
could generally see this happening
i could generally see this happening as
well because it would get really good
positive
um
run up to it would get really good the
media would really be outside with this
and it could be a really exciting
project
if tim timber doesn't [ __ ] it up which
is a massive risk
so
charlie chocolate factory makes me want
to hurt myself
this movie though beetlejuice 2
beetlejuice the original is one of my
favorite movies it could be freaking
awesome
there's also a lot of people like winona
ryder michael keaton you know remember
my michael keaton before birdman was
kind of a bit of a wandering actor he
hadn't really had a hit for a long time
so 15 years ago the beetlejuice
sequel didn't really have any momentum
behind it but michael keaton's had a
complete resurgence he's back the top of
his game winona ryder thanks to stranger
things has shown an acting range that we
didn't have no clue she had
and obviously if johnny depp joined the
the role this could be his first big
comeback after this mess of a trial
so
let's talk about the trial
for first of all
i'm not biased in a lot of the um
channels that we see talking about this
um i listen to a little like popcorn
planet which is one channel that's done
very very well off the back of trials
like this
and um they are very biased
johnny depp is innocent and it's as
simple as that that's there's no other
possibility johnny depp is 100
innocent
now i don't
necessarily lean that way because in my
personal experience nobody's 100
innocent
nobody is 100 percent guilty a lot of
the time even though i'm heard
really is trying to look 100 guilty
um and she's put a lot of effort into
looking 100 guilty but let's hope you
know i generally don't think nobody is
evil um
but i do have personal reasons why i've
not discussed this before and those
reasons are basically that damn it
basically
i've been through something similar
myself
so um on a personal level i'll say to
you that um i am actually on my second
marriage
um and
my first marriage was a nightmare and
ended very very badly ended in the
courts there were lots and lots of
accusations thrown around and i will be
the first one to say that i was not 100
innocent i
had my contribution to why that marriage
failed
um
but then
when the fighting started there was lots
and lots of you know
accusations and things um about
yeah where are the young whacky actors
that's that is true i can't think of
many well that's what i think about that
um good comment wrong
so um bob um so
there were then lots of accusations and
lies built on lies and i can tell you
from my own
personal experience
people are more than willing to lie
blatantly lie and tell
massive
hurtful lies
to get what they want
and that seems to me what johnny depp
has been suffering with
i can also handle my heart say
that when somebody's accused of
something they haven't done
they will fight hammer on earth they
will you know they will actually go
beyond what is
reasonable to try to defend their honor
and try to get their name back
now johnny depp that's actually caused
him to have a problem with his career
it's got him sacked from things like the
grindelwald character which actually
was the best thing in that second harry
potter in the fantastic beasts
johnny depp's character character's
grindelwald was fantastic it was i had a
load of really crappy press at the time
because everything was kicking off with
the whole amber heard amateur thing
um but actually watching the film now
you look back and it's his character is
fantastic and one of the things i really
really miss about um
[Music]
the third film was that the grindelwald
character was just not as good he was
far more reserved and it just wasn't
very evil
i just wish johnny depp had been able to
appear in it i think it would have made
sense it's a much better film than the
second one the third one and it would
have been even better again if johnny
depp had been in it
so from my personal point of view again
like i said i don't generally believe
that anyone is 100 innocent either way
but neither is anyone 100 guilty either
way generally um in normal circumstances
don't mean like psychopaths when they're
going killing sprees i'm not sort of
like
go yeah but what about yourself bringing
i'm not thinking about that sort of
thing um i'm thinking you know like
these pretty when couples go at each
other like this and there's so much
anger
but what i will say is that um amber
heard has done a really good job of
adding to those lies
um and i said that is something i
experienced when i was going through
court
and i was trying to keep my good name i
am i
this the the other person involved tried
to get me sacked from my job at the time
um they tried to ruin my life um they
did everything they possibly could to
get what they wanted and when one lie
didn't work they just switched to a more
grotesque lie to try and get what they
wanted
um i'm not gonna go on and on and on
about my own personal situation on that
because you know it's delicate and i'm
just going to cause myself problems
but this is why i haven't spoken about
it because i see a man
in johnny depp
that's trying to get his name back
and the reasons why he's fighting so
hard to get his name back isn't
necessarily for his career which even
though i'm sure that's a big part of it
because he's got a crew that's worth
hundreds of millions of dollars
but it is for his children
i know that the thing that hurts me the
most is that my children believe some of
these lies and he desperately doesn't
want that but johnny depp is not
innocent and if i'm gonna have my heart
say
um
[Music]
i think i'm gonna play the clark
griswold character in the vacation
movies
you know what if they did that again now
i'm not sure they couldn't when they did
the vacation movie recently that chapa
was named i can't remember who's in the
office and stuff i can't remember his
name he was not as good
um chevy chase is one of those actors
that i absolutely adore and he um is is
amazing in the vacation movies and lots
of other movies like um
uh oh it's the one where he's dead again
oh gonna forget i'm the invisible man
even
horrible person in real life absolutely
awful but in those movies you know
i i believe
you know she it was amazing
peter you're right
so we'll talk about the trial again
she has lied repeatedly and been found
out
do i think that'll actually go against
when it comes to the final verdict the
problem is
technically
even though she's lied that's not really
what the case is about they have to
prove that she's lied with the intent
to harm and to actually cause harm
and i don't think
she did it to cause harm necessarily i
think she did it to progress her career
she saw the metoo movement and she
thought i'll have a bit of that thank
you
and so made these accusations
um and i don't think she ever imagined
johnny depp would fight back i genuinely
think she believed his manliness or
whatever would stop him from from
actually standing by going you know what
no i was the one that was abused
and she says as much repeatedly in the
video in in the different videos and
different recordings but i would view
that actually i believed amber heard at
first because johnny depp is a bit of a
weird fella
he does drink too much he does take
drugs he has admitted to those things he
has stood up and said yes i take drugs
but no i don't take handfuls of mdma
because that would kill me
and but he's a drug addict he is
potentially an alcoholic he can be
aggressive
but then we see the videos within like
slamming
cupboard doors and things and you gotta
say
that doesn't look to me like a violent
person that looks like a person that's
being pushed by a woman who knows
exactly what she's doing
in the full video of her of him banging
doors and getting annoyed you see her
giggle first and then point the camera
at him and then do it in a way that he
sees the camera he then says what are
you doing you're recording me again and
comes over and takes the phone off and
gets now annoyed i'm sorry but there
isn't a human being on earth that
wouldn't get angry in that situation
particularly if they're a bit drunk
johnny depp is a human being but under
the
spotlight of this trial he occasionally
has looked like
not the nicest person in the world and
to be honest i really hope he gets some
help because for his children's sake if
nothing else
but amber heard
has repeatedly
and repeatedly
lied
actively lied
and allied in ways that is
um
planned
the injury to her face on the day that
she put in the um a temporary
restraining order and basically told
team damn it told tmz
to be there and where she would pause
and all these things these things have
basically
as good as being proven
it's lucky that's not how um so
he did she did that on purpose she did
that though i don't think necessarily to
hurt johnny depp but again to promote
her career
so if johnny depp wins this for one i
don't think he'll ever see 50 million
dollars i think at the second he wins
she will claim bankruptcy
um
and then
um you know
she's got enough money that she'll keep
her money if you know to me um
yes
i'm not saying it
um
i think he was yeah i actually think she
was trying to provoke him i think she
was intentionally trying to provoke him
and you can actually hear her almost
giggle when he comes over to her and
starts getting annoyed because i think
she knows he's not a violent person and
he wouldn't be violent
um
we all know the happy stoner as well
that when people just pass out when
they're stoned
but
um let's have a look i can't get two of
extras over the case for trial these
increases celebrity cultures yeah
they're two people that are very famous
amber heard less famous than johnny depp
obviously but now amber turd is probably
one of the most famous people on the
planet right now
everything that they said they're from
this psychology side of things that's
something else i've got experience of is
the psychology side of things now johnny
depp to me seems like the sort of person
that
is a celebrity he's been caught and
celebrity from a very young age and yes
he drinks too much he takes drugs but
this is he's done it his entire life he
wants to be a rock and roll star for
god's sake
that doesn't assume he's violent
all the things with the psychology over
this trial though have been very clear
and you've got to be
very clear on this as well that
she's the only one to have had
um
actually proper psychological assessment
and
she came off as harry and puts
borderline personality disorders
borderline personality disorders that
completely tagged with what she was
being accused of
narcissist yes
somebody that would deflect and blame
yes somebody that genuinely probably
believes a lot of her lies and that is
something else that people can't quite
get their heads around
she probably believes a lot of what
she's saying now don't get me wrong
she's the worst actress in the world and
they're going
to be oh whatever my dog stood up or
whatever it was and then be like
look i'm crying no you know you're not
crying there's no tears we know what
crying looks like you're just pulling a
face
um but
so you know she's the worst actor in the
world
but she probably does believe a lot of
what she's saying because she'll told
herself a lie so much but the lie is
also so important to her narrative
that she starts to believe it in my
experience i genuinely believe that my
the other person involved in that
situation believes what they accused me
of or at the very least just talked
herself into a point where
she almost believes it um
that's
really really horrific and you know but
it does happen
so what do i think the the results going
to be
i actually think johnny depp could lose
this trial
but i don't think he'll lose and have to
pay amber heard any money because i
think she'll lose as well i don't think
the jury can really
say either way i think they will get to
a point where they they almost say well
this is this was a toxic marriage it was
a toxic relationship and you're as bad
as each other it's a wish really the
judge could knock their heads together
and just go get out of my court and stop
wasting everyone's time
um you're as bad as each other sort of
thing um but
um
the bin laden was trying to trigger a
weeping episode and she failed it's 100
100 agree
um
so
she um you know she yes so so so
technically i think that might be a bit
of um
a non-event when it comes to the finale
and like i said even if she does win um
even if he does win yeah i don't think
he'll ever see any money
one of the interesting things about that
is she keeps complaining that she
couldn't give the money to the charities
she's pledged it and i know they argue
that well she's pledged it but she can't
give it to them just yet because of tax
they give it an installment sort of
thing so she's slowly intending to give
it to them she has to do it over stages
and they said well i can't now then
because i've been sued apparently she's
not paying illegal fees a home insurance
provider is paying illegal fees because
it's part of a policy um she couldn't do
it if it was a court case uh a legal
court case but because it's a defamation
case in a civil case she's been able to
claim on her insurance that's a six
million quid
bill that the insurance potential is
playing so she's moaning about how this
this court case is costing her fortune
she's not even paying it she's not even
paying the legal fees
um
let's have a look at what people are
saying general grievous i don't believe
anyone the principal legal says info
proven guilty not guilty until
provincial i don't trust on gender race
or anything else over evidence 100
and
in this case a lot of the evidence is
circumstantial
a lot of the evidence makes them both
look like
not the most pleasant people in the
world
but i would argue in that that they are
in an incredibly
um
toxic environment where they were
provoking each other she was 100
provoking him um and
that's what's complicated the situation
i wish in a way johnny depp had left
sooner and gunka but also i think it's
very clear as well that johnny depp
didn't want to go to court over this he
went over the court over the sun he lost
that case basically
he lost that case because
he was sue in the sun and the sun all
the sun had to prove was that they had
tried to do their best to prove what
they were being told is true so even
though they said
johnny depp's an abuser what they
actually said was amber heard says
johnny depp is an abuser so they got
away with that on that technicality this
court case is different so we should
really separate those two court cases
the london case and the american case
the america case is very much different
it's very much amber versus debt
definitely number
the point i'm trying to make here is
that with my legal situation i i won the
case
um i had all of the accusations that are
about me dropped or proven to be not
true
but i still lost
because like
um a lot of the problems johnny depths
having the assumption in law is that the
woman is right if they make accusations
so
i'm not going to go into it but i lost
my case in really even though i won
johnny depp's situation is completely
the opposite he could lose this case and
as long as he doesn't have to give amber
heard millions of dollars hundreds of
millions which i don't think that would
ever happen
he's won
because he's going to have won and he
has won
public opinion
he's gone from being the a complete
scumbag wife beater
to not only considered innocent but
actually considered
i've spoke to people goes
you know how didn't he hit her
you know just like i'm like like
somebody's acting like this hey this man
has the patience of a saint i would say
he's probably so too stunned to be able
to do but
johnny depp has come out of this as yes
he's a drug addict yes he's an alcoholic
yes he's a is a tortured soul in some
ways but i think he's he thinks he's a
rock star he wants to be a rock star um
but he's come out of it with people's
sympathy he's come out of it laughing
and joking and
you know waving at the crowd and doing
all these things but he's come out of it
looking completely innocent and public
opinion has completely gone into his
favor and i can't
argue
with that
because it has i have been a johnny depp
fan
in movies since i saw him in a film
called nick of time
years ago it was before 24 came out and
it was a movie that was done in real
time he was young i thought he was
probably early 20s or something um i
loved that film um it's a really good
movie and that's when i thought i
realized thing i never liked edward
scissorhands i thought you know
but not big fighting but
um but then obviously captain jack
i see all the um amber heard has accused
him of not being a very charitable
person but then you see him going to
hospitals and going to schools and it
not being announced dressed as captain
jack and spending hours
hours wandering around the hospitals
talking to the kids playing with the
kids
um
you know we've seen video and video and
video of these um you know he he just
where they were filming the first um
parts of the caribbean he just turned up
at all the schools in the area and was
just talking but as captain jack full
thing never came out of it
that to me is yes he can give millions
of dollars he's he's shown that he gives
millions of dollars to charities and to
to people to help them he's a patron of
the arts etc but more importantly he
gives his time and for somebody like
johnny depp that's far more valuable in
lots of ways
than you know putting his name to things
turning up to these places actually
having like one-to-one
contact with people that is something
that amber heard has never done and will
never do
she tried to look like the
philanthropist
good-hearted person
but really it was just a ploy to get
people on the side
she said i'm a member of the me too
movement as well i want to progress my
career and i'll even give money to
charity to prove that i'm serious
but really all she was doing was giving
a little bit away
on the plan of making more later she was
investing in her career if you like and
as it turned out she never gave him the
money anyway
so a man of mine went through something
somewhere they're part of the disorder
and accused him of terrible things
against her children and nearly drove
him to suicide his life was awful for
years peter i can't handle my heart say
that
um i
know exactly what your friend went
through
and that is a sad thing that i don't
want to um
like say talk about much um but
it's
when it's your kids involved
the thing is that like if i stand up to
court and i get angry
i'm angry and emotion overly emotional
and whatever else even though it's my
kids i want to kick the door and i want
to you know i want to scream this isn't
fair
but then if you don't do that and you
stay calm then where's your emotion your
emotions what's going on so from a man
point of view
you're damned if you're doing damned if
you don't and i have to admit
at the end of the court case
when they're doing their final um
closing argument
that the one um
uh the dumbass that that um that
objected to his own question i forget
his name um he actually said that if you
for one you have to believe that johnny
depp was never abusive to amber ever he
never raised his hand to her
and actually i believe he didn't
um but then he says that basically
[Music]
i nearly stopped myself with her
if you
what message are you sending to abused
women
and to the next victim that if you
um go against amber heard and that made
my blood boil
because just because she's a woman and
she's accusing somebody of abuse doesn't
mean
it's true
people accuse people of things they
didn't do all the time and that
shouldn't take anything away from real
victims i'm not actually sorry a false
accusation does take a lot away from
real victims
we shouldn't say that because johnny
depp is innocent means that somebody
else is guilty that's not how the law
works
but we have to look at the evidence
but for them to make that argument
to me screamed out how desperate they
are
to make that argument that if you think
she's guilty
and he's innocent then you're basically
saying that every woman that has ever
been abused is guilty and
you know we're tarnishing that next
person that's going to accuse somebody
of
if something horrible has been done to
them no
there has to be evidence and we have to
be fair we have to say that just because
she's a woman really is irrelevant what
does the evidence say
and in this case the evidence proves
over and over and over again that
she is a liar
and the one thing i do like is the judge
actually said
um
that if you can counteract in one lie
you can assume everything is a lie
and i cannot tell you one thing that i
think johnny depp was proven to actually
be a liar about but we can list off
anything with amber herds
depp is working hard to his name and i
think he's honestly when he says he's
doing it for his children i genuinely
believe him um
bob gives an industry was told not to
say he loves his children
yeah because it just as for a bloke
it's it's not fair the the the law even
though particularly in the uk now the
legal system is supposed to be weighted
evenly particularly when it comes to
maintenance and things like this it's
not the assumption is the woman is
guilty i tell you in my case
i'm sure i should say this
i was accused of things i wasn't allowed
to see my kids
i was proved innocent
she was proved to have
psychological
stuff bad things um i still wasn't i'd
see my kids that's how it worked it's
it's horrible but even when i was proven
to be innocent the assumption still was
that i couldn't be
i we had to wait for the children to be
okay with me before you know there was
but but she wasn't
forced to do anything it's just like the
the the law is so
horribly twisted
um
not in evidence but towards as an
assumption
of certain things and i probably
shouldn't have said that but
never mind right so
i wanted to do that video
i wanted to talk about that
um i wanted to talk about beetlejuice
too a bit more but you know
we can't um uh let's let's hope i just
get green lit i will repeat that and it
is just a rumor at the moment um but i
do really think the momentum is in its
favor and i think it might even get
announced as soon as this trial's over i
don't think it'll get announced at the
moment even though it might be already
agreed i think they will wait till after
the trial simply because it would look
quite negative i think they would get
some negative press if they did it
during the trial so i think within a
week or two the trial ending well
there's still a bit momentum there's
still a bit of public interest this
project will get greenlit
um and then it'll be interesting to see
what happens with disney
and parts of the caribbean because you
know johnny depper said he wouldn't
they'd have to pay him 300 million
dollars and 300 llamas or lemurs or
whatever it was to get him back
and he would never work for them again
i suspect disney will be crawling on
their hands and knees to say
look we're really sorry we believed that
nutter we're so sorry um
come on let's have one last crack
let's have one last goodbye and say
tara to a great character and whatever
you think about the last couple of
movies
captain jack sparrow is a great
character
let's give him the send-off he deserves
and to be honest
i think johnny depp will go for it so
let's fingers crossed on that one
we need a cultural reset maybe gender
relations can rebalance after a great
depression right maybe
people it's great to remember that every
white male falsely accused 100 women or
minorities have been falsely accused
yeah
um it's almost as if amberhead's
ultimate goal is to bring johnny depp
good name down as if it was a trophy to
her yeah and i think like i said and and
in the meantime she she i think she was
angry she was
blamed him for everything but also she
saw an opportunity
to further her career
and that is almost as sick as everything
else to be honest so hey thank you so
much for everybody that's watched um
please get in the comments after i'm
gone tell me what you think a bit more
um as
you saw a little bit earlier there we
have the um
oh where am i at now
merchandising please help us as a
channel grow and i need to make money so
i can work less so i can do this more
and there's some brilliant stargate
designs i've got i've got i've just
ordered my stargate and there's three
stargate designs you have to pick which
team you are sg-1 sga or sgu um i've
picked my team so that t-shirt's on its
way um please go and have a look at
soundtrack.com
um also please if you are new to the
channel please like subscribe hit the
bell notification it really helps us out
and you can consider becoming a fully
fledged side tracker
hit the join button
please guys as always stay really really
safe and um
maybe we'll get an answer to the johnny
jeff trial tomorrow
fingers crossed
see you guys
[Music]
you